-This is -- Again, like I said
in the intro,
this is a big deal
for me, for the show
to have two guests on
the same night.
It's starting to bring bac
a little bit of normalcy.
-I know.
And I'm really excited to be
on the show with
Hollywood's most eligible
bachelor, Pete Davidson.
-Yeah, it's a big deal, right?
-Yeah.
-I mean -- And he doesn't even
live in Hollywood,
and, yet, he's the number-on
most eligible bachelor.
That's the level of
his eligibility.
-I know.
I heard he's dating
Melinda Gates now or something
-Really?
-This is what I --
Twitter said it.
-He got that fast?
-Yeah. I mean, I've been reading
about it all day on Twitter.
-Wow! You must have that
good Twitter.
-I'm just -- I was -- I mean
I saw him in the hallway.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
Whoa. Should I be
worried about my marriage?
-Yeah, no.
But you held on tight.
Congratulations.
-I did.
-At least we think.
-I survived Pete Davidson.
-You -- Congratulations,
by the way.
You are both married
to Joshua Jackson, no less
and you have a 1-year-old.
So you have had -- Obviously
a lot of us have had
a very unique
years, yours even more so.
Did you enjoy the time, though
It must have been nice
to spend time with a baby,
even though it was a
difficult year.
-I mean, it was kind of like -
It was --
I was lucky in that this is th
time when you just want to onl
cocoon with your baby,
like, when they're first born.
So, you know, we were really
lucky that that's kind of --
Everything was shut down.
And you also,
like -- Suddenly, you get this
like, psychotic mother-bea
instinct,
where you just want to guard
your baby from everyone.
And so, you know,
I think it saved me
from, like, a lot of weird
exchanges and altercations
-But you did -- You did just
travel to Jamaica.
How was she on the --
How was she on the flight?
Is she a good traveling baby
-She's so good on the plane!
She's like --
For her, it's like old hat
At this point, she's like,
"When are we landing?"
You know, she's taken
like six flights at this point
'cause, you know, obviously,
with what we do,
we're constantly moving around
And even just the year
she was born, you know,
in that year, we moved house
probably about five times.
Don't recommend.
-This is also
your upbringing, as well.
Now, were you born in the U.K.
grew up in Maryland?
-Yeah, born in England,
grew up in Peterborough,
then in Maryland.
Then I went to college
in Pittsburgh.
-So, now, this is --
You obviously are someone
with many accents.
You have Jamaican lineage,
as well, yes?
-Yes, I'm Jamaican.
-And, so, you can do them all,
but the Pittsburgh accent
is maybe one of
the most unique in the world
-Yes. You know this.
-Yes.
-You know this.
-Did you enjoy
the Pittsburgh accent?
-You know, I mean, it is -
I enjoyed -- It's -- Yes.
-Wow, that's a real --
That's a real convincing sell.
[ Both laugh ]
-It's its own thing,
Pittsburghese, you know?
-Yeah. Can you do it?
-A little bit. Not really.
-Okay.
-It's going to be bad.
Anyone from Pittsburgh,
I'm sorry.
-Okay.
-But, you know,
"Yinz going dahntahn?"
-That's pretty good!
That is -- You know,
that's passably good.
And it certainly is
the sort of go-to sentence
that I feel like people use.
-Yeah.
-Did you get involved or ever go
to any Pittsburgh sports events?
-I did.
You know, also, I was --
For a little bit,
I was a Miller Lite girl.
You know, so I spent a lot o
time drinking in Pittsburgh.
I was.
But, you know, for me,
I knew that when
I was going to come on here,
you were going to ask me
about the Pittsburgh thing
You ask your guests
to do a Pittsburgh accent.
And I was like,
"Everybody does that."
I thought instead, "Why don't
bring you something?"
-So I brought you some --
A little --
A little gift to you from me
so that you --
-That's so wonderful.
-Yeah.
-And it's in one of our bags
-Mm-hmm.
-Which definitely makes me
think you did the shopping
-I did do the shopping,
actually.
-Did you really?
-But I did ask for you guy
to bag it, okay?
-This is so wonderful.
Thank you.
Now, I've been told
I look very bad in hats.
Will you be honest with me
-Of course!
-Okay.
-Oh, my God. So good.
It's so good. Right, guys?
-Thank you. My God.
It feels great.
-Now, I have to be --
Full transparency.
I have to be really honest
Like, I brought you that
with ulterior motives.
-Which is?
-Well, see, the thing is -
So, my husband, right?
You know,
he's been on your show.
-Yes, he has.
-You know, and you come on you
show, you get a gift bag
and you get things
because you come on the show
-T-shirts, coffee mugs.
-Yeah.
And it's yours, special for you,
because you've been on the show.
-Yes, the understanding when w
give it to a guest is that
they will keep it
for themselves.
-Right. So, when I first met
my husband, you know,
which it was kind of -- Yo
know, we had a one-night stand
We're in a two-, three-yea
one-night stand now.
-Uh-huh.
-And he had invited me
to stay at his apartment
when he was not there.
-Oh, wow.
-And I went there,
and it was my birthday.
And I brought a bunch of m
girlfriends with me.
And, of course, you know, th
day after my birthday,
there was a
raiding of the closet.
And I know that one of
these friends of mine stole hi
"Late Night with Seth Meyers
T-shirt.
-I see. I see.
-Yeah.
So he told me that
I have to get him a shirt.
Like, he needs his own shirt
now, another one.
-Mm-hmm.
-So I thought --
-We just -- We have really
serious rules
about the T-shirts.
I would love to do this
for Joshua.
I'd love to get you
out of a jam.
Also, you just gave me a hat
and that's less than a shirt
-But there's also --
There's also a face covering
And that's
a Steelers face covering.
-So, okay, okay, okay.
-Maybe this one time,
you could just --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. There you go.
-Thank God, because if
I went home empty-handed,
it would be a really
uncomfortable night.
-Okay.
You have to be honest with me.
Is it true that you watche
"Dawson's Creek" as a kid?
-Yes.
-And, now, were you --
You have to be double honest
Were you Team Pacey?
-Come -- First of all --
first of all, let's be real.
Who wasn't Team Pacey?
-Right?
-Let's be real.
-I mean, no offense to Dawson,
but, like,
it was all about Pacey.
-I mean, you know, we --
At our house,
we call it "Pacey's Creek.
-Exac--
-Yeah, you know.
-I was just going to say that.
-But this is true.
My -- I have not --
I'll just be honest.
I have not
watched "Dawson's Creek,"
but my wife was a big fan,
and she rewatched it
during quarantine.
And so I would just sort of hear
it on while she watched it
on her -- She would watch it
on her iPhone.
And then I would read
"The Odyssey."
We're very different.
Like, she likes that,
and I like --
You know,
in the original Greek --
-Yeah.
But, you know, can I just
say that, you know,
in "The Odyssey,"
I don't think that anybody
was buying anybody a wall.
-That's true. That's very true
-So there's that.
-And did he know this
when you met?
Did you -- How fast
did you, like, show your han
and was like, "I --"
-You know what?
I really -- I did not show
my hand at all.
First of all,
I saw him before he saw me
and when I saw him,
I was like, "I want that."
-Great.
-And then, when he saw me,
I was pretending like
I didn't see him.
So he had to yell across
the room to me.
And I was wearing this T-shirt
that said --
-"Dawson's Creek."
[ Laughter ]
-It said "Pacey's Creek." No
I was wearing another --
A T-shirt from a movie calle
"Sorry to Bother You."
And Tessa Thompson plays
a character called Detroit
and she has this
T-shirt that says,
"The future is
female ejaculation."
So that's the T-shirt
I was wearing.
-Wow!
-And, so, he shouts across
the room, "Detroit!"
And I was like...
-Wow!
-Yeah. And then he, like, come
over and he's like, "Hey."
You know, does this really cute,
charming thing that he does.
And just all night,
he just basically
followed me around the party
-Well, it certainly
seems to have been
an effective ploy on your part
-Oh, yeah.
I didn't let that --
I didn't let that thing go
until about like a month later
and then he realized, you know
But he felt that energy.
Do you know what I mean?
He felt it.
-Yeah.
Well, I tip my cap
to both of you.
It seems like you're very happy.
And congratulations on the baby.
And congratulations mostly
on getting a shirt out of me
'cause no one ever does.
What a delight to have you
here in studio.
Thank you so much for making
the time for us today.
-Thank you.
-Tom Clancy's "Without Remorse
available now on
Amazon Prime Video.